Lucy Edwards lost her sight at 17. what
page is a recipe for soup question mark
now she's helping to test an app running
arguably the most powerful AI ever
developed last question gpt4 can
understand human words and pictures
so this is why it's incredible because
now I've got all of these kukri books at
my disposal so the potential you think
life-changing for Lucy AI is clearly
making the world a better place
so why now has a six month pause on
developing even more powerful AI being
called for by the likes of Elon Musk and
over a thousand other experts they're
worried about things like misinformation
take fake images of Donald Trump being
arrested by police an event that never
happened but made almost Real by an
image generating AI
then there's AI is developing a mind of
their own gpt4 can pass exams but also
psychological tests of human
consciousness as we train those models
to be better and better at mocking
simulating human language they
spontaneously develop those very
Advanced very sophisticated properties
wait a year two three those models
they'll be so much better than us that
it probably will be very difficult for
us to comprehend even what you know what
those decisions mean
so what does a gpt4 think it thinks high
gpt4 do you have Consciousness as a Neo
language model I do not possess
Consciousness I do not have
self-awareness emotions or subjective
experiences my responses are based on
patterns found in the text Data I was
trained on
well that's a relief or is it an ai's
ability to even appear like it has
Consciousness is still a major
development if you expected so soon one
of the things that I think has really
struck me is the cycle of development to
release seems very very quick
in machine learning and AI it feels like
we're all subjects in some large
uncontrolled experiment
a lot of good might come out of this but
a lot of unintended consequences might
come out of this too
there's hardly a better example of trust
in technology than someone relying on it
to see but the speed at which AI is
growing is transcending our ability to
understand it let alone decide how best
to prepare for the consequences Tom
Clark Sky News